c'est le joyau de la bourgogne le clos
de tahar 280 millions d'euros
le domaine viticole le plus cher de
france la famille pinault se l'est
offert en octobre 2010 est clos des
lambrays domaine bono du martray les
grands crus en monopole se vendent
désormais plus de 100 millions d'euros
chacun cette spéculation fait flamber
les prix de toutes les parcelles de
côte-d'or avec des écarts très
importants de douze mille 700 euros
l'hectare pour une appellation régionale
après que trois millions d'euros pour un
premier cru les grands crus atteignent
facilement 14 millions d'euros l'hectare
le prix de la rareté et de la qualité
neuf mille 500 hectares de vignes en
côte d'or aujourd'hui c'est rien c'est
très très peu c'est vraiment une petite
niche viticole par rapport aux centaines
de milliers d'hectares de vignes qui
existent dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui fait sa valeur
c'est ce qui fait sa valeur seuls 150 à
200 hectares change de mains chaque
année en côte d'or en toute discrétion
thierry gaudillère et journaliste
viticole depuis 30 ans pour lui le
secteur est en pleine restructuration
économique la rentabilité ne se fait pas
tant par la bouteille vendue mais par le
retour sur investissement sur le prix
des terres en cinq ans les prix des
terres a été en côte d'or un jeu par le
mépris des terres viticoles a été
multiplié par trois fini le propriétaire
exploitant beaucoup de viticulteurs ont
désormais recours à des groupements
fonciers viticoles pour accéder à la
terre il y à des investisseurs qui
achètent des parts dans un groupement
foncier tout simplement et et chaque
année ils sont rémunérés par des
bouteilles sur la production la folie
des grandeurs touche surtout la côte
d'or dans le mâconnais les prix
plafonnent à 260 milles euros l'hectare
pour les premiers crus de pouilly fuissé
et à 400000 euros dans le chablisien ses
vignobles bourguignons pourraient
devenir la nouvelle terre promise